Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, ich bin Dr. Matt.
Ich bin zuständig aus für Sie.
Ich möchte mit Ihnen über Ihre Beschwerden sprechen.
Aber so als brauche ich ein paar Personen nicht an Daten.
Dann sprechen wir über Ihre Beschwerden.
Wie lautet Ihr Name?
Mein Name ist Ralph Kühler.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Nachnamen bestabieren?
Ralph Kühler.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Kühler?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wo haben Sie genau geboren?
Am 8. Mai 65.
Am 8. Mai 65, ja?
Ja, ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 58 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,78 m.
Und ich wiege 87 kg.
1,78 m.
Und wie wiegen Sie?
87 kg.
Okay.
Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was für Sie tun?
Was für Sie haben Sie?
Ich bin ein bisschen eilig zu einem Termin gelaufen.
Ich bin selbstständig.
Ich hatte einen wichtigen Termin bei der Arbeit.
Ich habe mittags ein bisschen verspätet.
Dann bin ich zügig in meinem Büro gelaufen.
Ich hatte die Treppe hochgelaufen.
Da hatte ich mit einmal solche Schmerzen in der Brust.
Ich hatte das Gefühl, ich hatte Angstzustände.
Das ist mir in den Arm reingeschossen.
Hier in den Unterkiefer.
Ich habe heftig Angst bekommen.
Dann habe ich gedacht,
ich gehe in die Brust.
Ich habe mir die Brust in die Brust gekauft.
Dann habe ich gedacht,
ich kann jetzt nicht mehr.
Mir ist unheimlich schlecht geworden.
Übergeben habe ich mich gar nicht.
Mir ist so schlecht gewesen.
Mir ist der Schweiß mit einmal in Strömen runtergelaufen.
Dann hat mich ein Kollege.
Er hat gesehen,
dass es mir nicht gut ging.
Er hat mich gleich in die Klinik gewacht.
Wie ist es bei uns gekommen?
Mein Kollege hat mich ins Auto gesetzt.
Er ist mit mir direkt hergekommen.
Können Sie bitte diese Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Rennen, dumpf?
Ja, sie sind wirklich, das brennt.
Ich habe zusätzlich ein ganz dumpfes Druckgefühl.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass ich gar nicht richtig atmen kann.
Herr Kühler,
wir müssen jetzt
eine Ecke schreiben.
Ich soll die Station aufnehmen.
Gleichzeitig werden wir uns gleich weiter.
Soll ich Sie an der Monitor anschließen?
Ja, ich werde Sie anschließen.
Ich werde Sie anschließen.
Ich werde Sie an der Monitor anschließen.
Jetzt setzen wir fort.
Ist Ihnen dann über?
Ja, mir ist schlecht.
Vorhin war das ganz besonders schlimm.
Jetzt ist es schon wieder ein klein bisschen besser.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig im eigentlichen Sinne eigentlich nicht.
Nein.
Würden Sie Schwarzwörter maugen?
Wirklich Schmerzen, die richtig panic gemacht haben.
Zum Glück ist es jetzt vorbei oder deutlich besser.
Aber fuh.
Ich würde schon sagen, die waren bei 8.
Also es waren sehr starke
und so sehr so Angstanklösen die Schmerzen.
Okay.
Machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Herr Kühler, wir sind für Sie da.
Ich bin jetzt im Vennös zugehört.
Okay.
Und Herr Kühler, haben Sie schon früher solche Beschwerden gehabt?
Also seit ein paar Monaten kenne ich das, dass wenn ich die Treppe hochlaufe, ja,
dass ich so ein bisschen Beschwerden bekomme, ja,
dass ich dann so ein bisschen husten muss auf der Treppe oder dass ich so Herzklopfen habe.
Das kenne ich schon, aber bis vor Kurzem konnte ich problemlos vier Etagen hochgehen.
Das hat mir überhaupt nichts ausgemacht.
Früher haben Sie Schmessen bei Belastung, bei Belastung,
aber momentan haben Sie Schmessen in Ruhe auch, ja?
Ja, das hat halt viel länger gedauert als sonst und es war eben viel heftiger.
Ja, sonst habe ich das schon mal gehabt und dann ist es aber wieder weggegangen, ja?
Und jetzt, dass es also solche krassen Schmerzen sind
und eben auch mit diesen Axt zu stecken, das habe ich so noch nicht erlebt.
Ich kann aber stehen.
Okay.
Müssen Sie mehr Kissen beim Schlaf benutzen?
Ja, ich schlafe eigentlich so mit ein bis zwei Kissen in der Nacht normalerweise, ja.
Leider sind Sie untergeschwollt in der Weine?
Das merke ich noch nicht so aufgefallen.
Okay.
Müssen Sie in der Nacht oft auf der Toilette gehen?
Ja, das stimmt allerdings. Aber ich habe auch ein bisschen Probleme mit der Prostata.
Prostata, okay.
Okay, haben Sie Fieber?
Oh, habe ich jetzt nicht gemessen, aber Fieber ich fühle mich eigentlich nicht.
Okay, haben Sie doch andere Beschwäden, Herr Kühler?
Nein, das langt mir auch völlig diese Beschwerden.
Also das war schon so, dass es mir wirklich Angst gemacht hat
und sonst hätte ich mich auch nicht sofort ins Krankenhaus bringen lassen.
Okay, machen Sie sich bitte keine Sorge.
Wir sind die besten für Sie machen, damit Sie wieder gesund werden, okay?
Ja, das kriegt gut, ja.
Leiden Sie unter Verstoffung oder Dummfall?
Nee, zum Glück nicht.
Wie ist die Stuhlgang bei der Prostata?
Also ja, wie gesagt, mit dem Wasser lassen, mit der Prostata, ja, da gibt es schon mal ein bisschen Probleme.
Aber Stuhlgang, das läuft ganz normal.
Okay, haben Sie in der letzten Zeit Abortosegeln genommen?
Nee, das ist alles stabil.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, wenn ich nachts nicht immer mal auf die Toilette müsste.
Ja, aber Sie müssten...
Manchmal ist es schon auch so, dann nehme ich mit dem Zweiten Kissen,
dass ich so nachts das Gefühl habe, ja, vielleicht ist das doch besser,
wenn ich ein bisschen höher liege.
Also dann habe ich das Gefühl, ich kann nicht so gut Luft kriegen
und dann mache ich mir ein bisschen gemütlicher im Bett.
Ich kann verstehen, okay.
Sie haben keine Probleme einzuschlafen, aber...
Ich wache dann zwischendurch mal auf, ja.
Sie müssten viel mal aufwachen, ja.
Ja, viel mal nicht, aber hin und wieder muss ich mal aufwachen, ja.
Okay, das ist klar.
Nun möchte ich mit Ihnen über Ihr Vorgeschichte sprechen.
Davor möchten Sie uns hinzufügen.
Hm, aber zuvor geschüßt in meinem Alter ist jetzt für mich immer etwas zu sagen, ne?
Okay, weiten Sie sich irgendwie ganz weit an Vorallegrafen?
Ja, also ich habe schon längere Zeit so ein Diabetes Typ 2
und der wird behandelt mit Formin.
Da nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Und was man auch festgestellt hat, dass ich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck habe
und dass ich erhöhte Blutfettwerte habe.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie da runter?
Mit dem Blutdruck und dem Blutdruck?
Dann hat man das festgestellt, ja, so ziemlich zeitgleich mit dem Diabetes.
Also auch ungefähr vor fünf Jahren.
Vor fünf Jahren, okay.
Was für Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Blutdruck?
Ja, dann nehme ich so ein Betablocker, ich weiß gar nicht so genau, wie der heißt.
Nehm ich morgens eine Tablette und dann nehme ich auch noch in der Aprilen.
Also gegen erhöhte Blutdruck?
Ich weiß nicht, dann nehme ich eigentlich nichts.
Also ich versuche ein bisschen vernünftig zu essen,
aber Medikamente nehme ich nicht dagegen.
Okay, ververständlich.
Ich kann gerne die Dosierung von MedVormin, zum Beispiel Otabetterbürokor,
in der Aprilen.
Also ich weiß nur, bei MedVormin steht tausend drauf,
weil den anderen kann ich Ihnen nicht genau sagen, wie viel da drin ist.
Ich weiß nur, dass ich das alles morgens nehme.
Okay, aber kein Problem.
Ich kann gerne veganhaushalts und fragen.
Ja, die wissen da genau Bescheid, genau.
Leider sind Sie noch andere Vorerkrankungen?
Niesons.
Eigentlich habe ich mich immer ganz fit gefühlt,
aber wie gesagt, jetzt diese Geschichte, das macht mir schon ein bisschen Sorgen.
Okay, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie auch Großbrot hat,
bis wir das haben.
Irgendwelche Frankheiten festgestellt wurden oder?
Nein, also man hat das nur festgestellt,
dass sie ein bisschen vergrößert ist.
Und deswegen muss ich halt Nachtzeichen auf die Toilette.
Aber ich nehme da keine Medikamente.
Seit wann neiden Sie unter Prostatorbeschwad?
Das ist noch nicht lange, vielleicht so zwei Jahre oder so.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Flüller.
Außer MedVormin, MedVormin und einer April.
Nehmen Sie noch eine Medikamentein?
Nee, das ist ja auch schon eine Menge, ne?
Okay, alles gut.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Wenn ich so überlege, nicht.
Ist noch alles dran an mir.
Nein, ich bin noch nie operiert worden.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Wo werden Sie außer anderem Grundstationen aufgenommen?
Ja, ich hatte mal vor, oh, das ist schon Jahre her,
da hatte ich meinen Autounfall.
Und da war man sich nicht ganz sicher,
ob ich mir irgendwo am Kopf was getan habe.
Da war ich mal eine Nacht für Beobachtung stationär in der Klinik.
Aber das war sie auch dann schon.
Das hat sich dann rausgestellt, dass da nichts passiert ist.
Okay.
Hatten Sie damals irgendwelche Gehirnerschüttelung
oder irgendwelche Koffer?
Ja, das hatten die befürchtet.
Und weil ich halt allein stehen bin,
haben die gedacht, sie nehmen mich stationär auf.
Aber hat sich dann rausgestellt, dass alles in Ordnung war.
Gott sei Dank.
Waren Sie damals verustet?
Nee, nee, nee.
Sind bei Ihnen aller Regien bekannt?
Ja, ich habe zwei ein bisschen lästiger Allergien.
Das eine ist ein unangenehmer Latex-Allergie.
Da bekomme ich so Hautausschlag und Rötung.
Und was ich auch überhaupt nicht nehmen darf, ist Novalgien.
Da reagiere ich auch mit Hautausschlag,
aber auch so mit ausgeprägter Luftnot.
Also das muss ich wirklich vermeiden.
Okay.
Fragen Sie nicht Produkte, getreite Produkte,
ob es oder Gemüse?
Essen und trinken kann ich alles.
Gut.
Okay, Herr Grüner, können Sie mir sagen, ob Sie rauchen?
Kann ich Ihnen sagen, ja, ich rauche, aber ich rauche fast nicht mehr.
Also seit zwei Jahren habe ich das deutlich eingeschränkt.
Ich rauche nur noch so zwischen fünf und zehn Zigaretten am Tag.
Und früher habe ich jahrelang ein Päckchen am Tag geraucht.
Und ja, dann habe ich gemerkt, dass es nicht so gut ist
und habe das eingeschränkt vor zwei Jahren.
Okay.
Seit wann haben Sie ein Schachtelprodukt geraucht?
Ja, das ging so mit 2022 oder so.
Als es dann mit dem Beruf losging und so nach dem Studium,
da ging das an mit dem kräftigen Rauchen.
Also ungefähr 25 Jahre oder so,
das habe ich so viel geraucht.
Aber Sie haben sehr gut ein Schachtelprodukt gegriffen,
dass Sie mit dem Rauchen reduziert haben.
Ja, ich finde diese Entscheidung sehr wichtig für Ihre Gesundheit.
Okay, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Alkohol.
Also ich trinke gelegentlich mit meinem Glas Wein.
Wenn es etwas zu feiern gibt, was weiß ich,
wenn es ein netter Abend ist, auch mal zwei Gläser,
aber eigentlich eher selten.
Trinken Sie täglich ein Glas Wein, oder?
Nein, nein, nein.
Nur gelegentlich.
Also wenn es eine Gelegenheit gibt,
mit Freunden zusammenzusitzen,
oder mal auch abends am Wochenende für mich alleine,
aber normalerweise trinke ich nur in Gesellschaft.
Ich kann gleich stehen.
Okay.
Würde ich in der Messung Musik fragen,
ob Sie Kontakt mit dem Drücken haben?
Ich habe noch nie etwas zu tun gehabt.
Okay, Herr Kohler, was ist Ihr Erfamilienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet, aber bin gerade im Trennungsjahr.
Im Trennungsjahr.
Okay, haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder.
Sind die gesund?
Die Kinder sind gesund, ja.
Okay, Gott sei Dank.
Wollen Sie mit Ihrer Kinder zusammen?
Nein, nein, die Kinder sind bei meiner Frau.
Sie wohnen alleine, oder?
Ich wohn alleine, ja.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von der Welt?
Ich bin in der Architekt.
Ich bin selbstständig, ne?
Leiden Sie unter der pädagogischen Träuse?
Ja, hin und wieder ist es schon mal stressig,
wenn man einen kritischen Kunden hat
oder wenn etwas mit den Aufträgen nicht so funktioniert.
Jetzt haben wir manchmal Lieferprobleme.
Das ist dann schon manchmal stressig, ja, würde ich sagen.
Okay.
Aber wenn Sie wollen, kann ich Ihnen eine klachartstichere Betreuung
empfehlen, vielleicht welchen Stress es ist?
Ja, erstmal muss ich jetzt gucken,
dass das hier mit diesen komischen Beschwerden besser wird, ja.
Okay, wir machen später das.
Okay, gibt es in der Familie irgendwelche Korakranke,
oder halt kühler?
Ja, meine Mutter hat auch so ein Altersdiabetes.
Und mein Vater, der ist gestorben, der war aber 83 Jahre alt.
Also, der hatte eine Herzkrankheit
und ich weiß, dass er auch hohen Blutdruck hatte.
Hast du einen Herzinfarkt oder wissen Sie?
Ich weiß nicht, ob der wirklich einen infarkt hatte.
Ich weiß nur, dass er letztendlich im Alter von 83,
dass er dann eine schwere Herzerkrankung hatte.
Was das genau war, kann ich Ihnen gar nicht sagen.
Okay, ist mir leider über ihre Verlust.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Geschwester habe ich nicht, nein.
Okay, Herr Güler, das war meine Frage.
Haben Sie die Geldwäsche frei oder möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Erst mal wüsste ich natürlich gerne,
haben Sie jetzt auf Ihrem EKG gesehen?
Was steckt Ihnen dahinter?
Was kann man denn jetzt sagen?
Wie kann ich das verhindern,
dass ich noch mal solche schrecklichen Schmerzen bekomme?
Sie haben recht, Herr Güler.
Wir haben einen EKG veranlasst.
Es gibt ein paar Veränderungen im EKG,
aber wir sollen auch Blutergebnisse warten.
Nach dem Ergebnis, nach dem die alle Ergebnisse da sind,
werde ich Ihnen genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Das klingt gut, ja, gut.
Und wie geht es jetzt weiter?
Sie sagten jetzt Blutergebnisse,
also müssen Sie mir Blut abnehmen und das machen Sie noch?
Ja, ich werde von Ihnen
jede 2-3 Stunden Blut abnehmen.
Deshalb muss ich so lange hier bleiben?
Leider müssen Sie im Krankenhaus bleiben.
Das habe ich mir jetzt nicht so vorgestellt.
Das ist eine sehr wichtige Umstände.
Die wichtigste ist,
dass Sie wieder gesund werden.
Okay, müssen Sie im Kleinkernhaus bleiben?
Außerdem werde ich auch
Ekokadioge viel durchführen.
Okay, außer dann veranlässt ich auch ein Röntgen.
Was wollen Sie röntgen? Was kann man da röntgen?
Ich möchte im Röntgen
irgendwelche anderen Veränderungen
auszuschließen oder andere Krankheiten auszuschließen.
Ach so, dass da nicht noch etwas anderes dahinter ist?
Na ja, gut.
Okay, danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Ich möchte etwas sagen.
Ich werde es heute mal in Bayern ablegen.
Meinem Vorfall war Radspieler.
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Das ist ja wirklich unglaublich.
Ich meine, umgekehrt haben wir das schon gehabt.
Das haben Sie vielleicht mal irgendwann gehört.
Ich habe zwei oder dreimal hintereinander.
Ich habe mich mit Leuten irgendeins feil gemacht
und der ist am nächsten Mal in den Puffen rangekommen.
Aber so rum könnte ich das gar nicht.
Aber es ist schade, dass ich vor der Prüfung
dieser Wand nicht gesehen habe.
Ja, deswegen.
Aber das ist wirklich ein blöder Zufall, oder?
Na ja, gut.
Ja, das ist ja unglaublich.
Dann haben Sie wahrscheinlich etwas gemerkt.
Wahrscheinlich haben Sie etwas gemerkt.
Ich habe Ihnen das kranke Kind unterschlagen.
Im Originalfall hat der Kinder Epilepsie im Originalfall.
Das habe ich aber nicht genommen.
Das habe ich unterschlagen.
Solange Sie mir das jetzt nicht erzählen, ist ja alles gut.
Das ist bei Dr. Gündis immer so.
Der kennt die Fälle so gut auswendig,
dass man gar nichts erzählen muss.
Das ist schon vorher, was man hat.
Da veränder ich schon immer die Namen,
damit er nicht schon beim ersten Namen zu nennen weiß,
um wen das geht.
Okay, gut.
Hat noch jemand mal Fragen?
Ich denke, alle Fragen gestellt, aber ich tat es nicht gefragt.
Stimmt.
Das ist ja auch ein Vor-Corona-Fall.
Da hat man noch nicht so viel nachgegeben,
um zu fragen.
Ich würde gerne sagen, als Patientgeschichte müssen wir ja
diese Akustik nicht eine Entfernung,
oder Stress, oder Zigarette.
Ja, als er gesagt hat, dass er Stress hat.
Das hat mich ein bisschen gestört, als Patient.
Nach dem Motto, jetzt haben wir doch gerade eine andere Baustelle.
Manchmal ist es auch, dass Kollegen mir sagen,
wenn ich viel rauche,
dass sie sagen, da sollten sie aber etwas tun.
Das ist nicht der Augenblick, um das zu diskutieren.
Das müsste man im anderen Zusammenhang machen.
Schöne Hinweise, danke.
Eine Hinweise, ich würde sagen,
dass es nicht der Augenblick gibt,
dass es nicht der Augenblick gibt.
Nur der hat gesagt, dass es ein Schmelzmittel gibt.
Das machen die Leute.
Ich habe eine Frage gestellt, wenn wir eine Herzkrankheit denken.
Es spricht jetzt der Kardiologe.
Er hat gefragt, ob ich so etwas früher schon mal hatte.
Ich habe gesagt, ich habe es gehabt, aber es ging immer nach ein paar Minuten.
Darauf kann man schließen, dass ich nichts gemacht habe und nicht beim Arzt war.
Nurler hat eine Frage gestellt, wie viele Minuten diese Schmerzen angedauert haben.
Ja, aber macht ein Patient da konkret richtige Angaben?
Ich glaube, in solch einem Augenblick kommen eine Minute bis Stunden vor.
Das kann man glaube ich sehr, sehr schwer einschätzen.
Ich glaube, niemand ist so cool, dass er auf die Uhr guckt und sagt, mal gucken, jetzt geht es los.
Wie lange hält das jetzt an?
Am Anfang der Schmerzen und der Dauert müssen wir...
Also genau, wann hat es angefangen? Wie lange hat es gedauert?
Gut, ich habe auch eine Frage.
wäre es auch wichtig vorher zu fragen, ob der Patient gegen Schmerzmittelallergie hat, bevor der Arzt Schmerzmittel gibt.
Ja klar, aber das hat er ja auch schon gesagt.
Er hat ja schon gesagt, dass er gefragt, ob ich Allergien habe und da habe ich bestätigt, dass ich eine Novalgienallergie habe.
Ja, deswegen habe ich eine Frage.
Aber er hat mir ja auch noch nicht direkt etwas zu geben, aber hat ja nur gesagt, wir können Ihnen nachher noch ein Schmerzmedikament geben.
Ich meine, so habe ich ihn verstanden.
Nein, diese Allergien gegen etwas Medikament hat er eingenommen, diese Fragen.
Zum Beispiel, die Settlerin oder die andere Medikamente hat er gebraucht.
Zum Beispiel diese Latexallergie hat.
Ja.
Das hat auch schon gesagt, aber der Patient hat irgendein Medikament gegen einen Genom?
Ach, aber dagegen Medikamente eingenommen hat.
Ja, aber das steht ja eigentlich nicht zur Debatte, sondern zur Debatte steht nur, sind bei Ihnen Allergien bekannt.
Das eine ist eine Latexallergie, das ist eine Kontaktallergie und das andere ist eben eine Novalgienallergie, wo er ja auch deutlich heftiger reagiert, nämlich mit Exantemen und Luftnot.
Ja.
Aber das sind ja Sachen, die irgendwo in der Vergangenheit festgestellt worden sind und wo man jetzt nur sagen muss, also bitte packt mich nicht mit Latexhanschuhen an und gebt mir keine Novalgien.
Das sind eigentlich ja die Erkenntnisse aus dieser Information.
Ja.
Können wir das jetzt noch mal für den Doktor?
Ja, das ist ja jetzt eine leichte Nummer für den Doktor.
Das macht ja jetzt, spult er seine Prüfung an.
Ja, okay.
Hallo Frau Oberratzen, wir haben einen neuen Patient, nämlich Rav Kühler.
Ich würde über ihn berichten, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich.
Rav Kühler ist 58 Jahre alt, 1,78 m groß, 87 kg schwer.
Er stelle sich heute bei uns wegen seit einigen Minuten Bescheidteerhänder brennender und rückender Torachschimmatzin sowie ein Gefühl im Hinterdammbrust, hinter dem Retro-Stannär vor.
Lieber Doktor, gucken Sie mal zwischendurch mich an, bitte.
Und nicht immer nur auf Ihren Zettel.
Ja.
Laut dem Patienten, die in der Mandibula schmerzen, so wie in den Linken ausschuldigen,
hat der Patient einige Bescheiden früher gehabt, aber in Rufe diese Bescheiden besser geworden sind.
Sind diese Bescheiden besser geworden?
Ja, aber diesmal haben die Bescheiden angedauert und im Laufe der Zeit schmerzen geworden.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde auf einer Schmerzsekrate von 0 bis 10 mit 8 bewertet.
Außerdem ist bei ihm die folgende Begleitstöme aufgefallen.
Nein, jetzt hat er nicht mehr sind, oder?
Ja.
Nein.
Nee, jetzt waren die weniger zum Glück, sonst hätte der hier nicht gewonnen.
Aber, ja, weniger.
Die sind besser geworden.
Nein, besser geworden.
Außerdem ist bei ihm die folgende Begleitstöme aufgefallen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Früher hat die Beleidigung abhängig, aber heute ist es nicht.
Aber nach der Belastung sind die Bescheiden aufgetrieben.
Nein, das Ganze hat angefangen, als er schnell ins Büro gelaufen ist und die Treppe hochgegangen ist.
Also unter Belastung ist das Ganze passiert.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Und Orthopne, Neuhtori sowie Todesangst.
Ich denke, nicht Begleitstöme, Orthopne, Neuhtori, Klackte.
Neuhtori vielleicht nicht, aber Begleitstöme bedeutet, dass diese Hautbescheiden mit Begleitstöme,
aber lange Zeit, Orthopne und lange Zeit, nicht die Tür sind.
Er klackte auch über.
Gut, aber jetzt lassen wir mal den Doktor, den Patienten steht dann.
Also, als Begleitstöme hat er ja ein paar Sachen gesagt.
Er hat gesagt, er kriegt keine Luft, er hat tierisch geschwitzt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich die Brüche rüberkomme.
Er war schlecht und er hatte Panik, er hatte Angst.
Panik hat nicht, ne?
Ja, auch Angst.
Und Beleitste, Kollegen hat gesagt, eine Kollegin mit Krankenhaus zusammen.
Ich denke, seine Kollegen, Zehn und diese Schweißausbrüche,
Beleitste, Neusea, Düstne, eine Symptome.
Beleitste, Beleitste.
Hallo.
Beleitste.
Ah, Blesse.
Ja, okay, das hat natürlich nur jemand anderes gesehen.
Ja, das hat er ja nicht gesagt.
Das hat er selber nicht beschrieben.
Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Der Patient hat andere gesagt.
Ja, andere gesagt.
Und eine Denken.
Sie wissen zu viel, auch schon gehört ist.
Okay, ja.
Gut, also, was habe ich alles gehabt?
Ich habe alles gesagt.
Was habe ich alles gehabt?
Es begleitet Symptome.
Machen Sie noch mal.
Als Begleitende Symptome gelagte er über Neusea,
Düstne, Todexarangst und Hyperhydrosia.
Ja, aber all.
Und da hinaus leidet er unter Nüchthorin,
Orthopne, ja, Nüchthorin und Orthopne.
Die tragen nach Fieber und Emesis, wo dann verneint.
Die vegetative Anamnese ergab in Somni,
in von Duschenlachstörung.
Anfragen an Krankungen sind bei ihm,
die Folgen dann bekannt, seit langem die Äpther ist Mehlietub,
Mehlietub 2, 5 Jahre.
Seit 5 Jahren,
Arterie, Hyperatoneut, Arterie, Hyperhydrosia.
Auch der Diabetes.
Seit 5 Jahren, die Äpther ist Mehlietub 2,
seit 5 Jahren Arterie alle Hyperatoneut,
Hyperlipidemi,
sowie seit 2 Jahren
Proistata Hyperpidlasia.
Er nimmt immer vorhin 1.000 Milligramm Tableten am Morgen,
Betablöckerdoseherung der Patient,
unbekannt am Morgen und am Abend,
1. April am Morgen und am Abend.
Nicht am Abend, nur am Morgen.
Am Morgen, ja.
Warum habe ich so?
Ich erinnere mich richtig, aber ich schreibe,
warum habe ich das geschrieben gesagt?
Er ist bisher noch nie operiert worden,
aber er wurde wegen eines Auto-Unfallstationen aufgenommen.
Er hat sich mit einer Erlegerung von Neuvalgien,
mit einer Erlegerung von Neuvalgien,
mit einer Erlegerung von Neuvalgien.
Neuvalgien, ja.
Der wirkt doch.
Unvertretlichkeiten wurden verneint.
Herr Kühler raucht seit 2 Jahren 5 bis 6 Zigaretten täglich.
Davor hat er seit dem 21. Lebensjahr 20 Zigaretten täglich geraucht.
Er trinkt ein Glas Wein gelegenlich.
Drohung von Konsum wurde verneint.
Herr Kühler ist verheiratet, aber er ist momentan in Trennungsjahr.
Er hat 3 Kinder, die Kinder sind gesund.
Er wohnt allein.
Er ist innenarchitekt vom Beruf und leidet unter viel Stress.
Der Vater des Patienten ist wegen einer Herzkrankheit verstorben.
Die Mutter des Patienten leidet an die Abethesminidus II.
Die einem Nestechanangaben dort am ehesten auf ein akutes Coronarsanthalm,
ein akutes Coronarsanthalm, ein differenzialer Diagnostik,
ein Herzinfarkt und eine Lungenambulierung.
Nein, der Herzinfarkt, nicht akutes Coronarsanthalm,
sondern ein Herzinfarkt, ein differenzialer Diagnosandere.
Ein differenzialer Diagnostik, ein Lungenambulierung,
ein Neumotorax, ein Neumotorax, ein Betrag.
Ich habe noch eine Frage als Oberärztin.
Haben Sie dann einen EKG gemacht?
Ja.
Und was war da auffällig?
Ja, ich erwarte im EKG erhöhte ST-Hebung und Scharferthebel.
Also es waren auffälligkeiten zu sehen?
Ja, oder?
Aber ich gebe auch ein EKG, das ist ein ER-Unterwartung.
Vielleicht.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten?
ST-Hebung, nicht ST-Strick-Hebung.
ST-Strick-Hebung.
Gut, was machen Sie mit den Patienten denn jetzt? Diagnostisch?
Ja, diagnostisch.
Ich höre auch Echokardiografie durch.
Mit Hilfe der Echokardiografie können wir Herzwand oder Herzklapfen
oder Körper-Herzwand beurteilen.
Aber machen Sie nicht vorher eine generelle körperliche Untersuchung?
Ja, genau.
So als werde ich körperlich untersuchen dürfen.
Ja, worauf gucken Sie da bei der körperlichen Untersuchung?
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung und bei Inspektionen
sehe ich irgendwelche Hautveränderungen
oder ich habe Angst,
oder irgendwelche Beine oder nicht.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
taste ich pyrotechnische Beine oder Herzstoss.
Ich würde Palpitation bestimmen.
Bei der Palpitation höre ich Lungen und Herztonen ab.
Gut.
Was machen Sie labortechnisch?
Vordränglich.
Im Labor kontrolliere ich sofort trockenen Öl und CKMB.
Ein kleines Produkt wie CAPBS-Gelaber,
oder Nier, oder Elektrolyt,
Gegenumungsparameter.
Okay.
Aber jetzt troponieren,
weil das Stichwort, das kommt, ist klarelogisch.
Gut.
Dann, operativ haben Sie schon gesagt,
Sie machen einen Herzecho.
Dann schauen wir mal,
was tatsächlich dahinter steckt bei dem Herrn Kühler.
Halten Sie mich auf dem laufenden,
was für Ergebnisse rauskommen.
Und dann hoffen wir mal,
dass das dem bald wieder besser geht.
Nein?
Nein.
Okay.
Gut.
Wir haben ein bisschen zwischendurch interveniert
und ein bisschen diskutiert.
Das ist natürlich ein bisschen irritierend.
Aber ich würde schon sagen,
dass Sie sprachlich eine sehr,
sehr gute Vorstellung geboten haben.
Ja, das war wirklich ziemlich cool.
Sowohl im Fragebereich ist ja so gut wie nix übergeblieben.
Ja.
Und ja, im Status.
Das war das einzige,
weil wir es vergessen haben.
Also mal ehrlich.
Ja.
Und natürlich.
Ich habe gesagt, fast Corona ist weg.
Ja, aber auch diese Frage weg.
Ja, aber was natürlich richtig war,
diese schnelle Reaktion,
dass sie gesagt haben, wir unterbrechen jetzt das Gespräch.
Und das ist elementar,
dass man den Mut hat zu sagen,
hallo, so können wir jetzt nicht weiter machen,
sondern wir müssen jetzt erstmal Metallparameter überprüfen.
Und ja.
Und in Ihrem Bericht,
meine ich, waren Sie auch sehr stetig.
Wie gesagt, wir haben Sie ein paar Mal unterbrochen.
Dadurch gab es so ein bisschen,
ich sage mal,
Konzentrationsprobleme,
aber das war wirklich super.
Ja.